okay rosita are you there
i am here and i'm ready to share just a
second
oh you can hear me and see me
and do you also see
my slides yes i do excellent
then
all right so let's get started uh it's
my great pleasure
to introduce rusicha piskach luzicha is
an associate professor
in the computer science department at
yale
uh she was previously a independent
researcher at max planck institute
and completed her phd from epfl in 2011.
she has won many awards for her work
including nsf career award
a facebook communications and networking
award
microsoft research award for software
engineering innovation foundations
so without further ado
thank you very much and uh thank you for
inviting me thank you albert so
uh this talk full title is using set
solvers
uh to prevent uh cause uh uh
failures in the cloud but if you look
what is uh then
follow up is an application talk when
albert reached out to me and asked me if
i could give this
additional talk on friday he asked me
whether that could be a talk
where we talk a little bit about
applications of uh
set solving and uh while uh
when vijay was mentioning he mentioned
those awards that are kind of very
uh applicable like networking like this
one
or uh software engineering i do consider
myself
a person who is working in uh you know
like developing new decision procedures
but nevertheless i'm really excited
about that work because
what you will see now is the joint work
with anan who use the that time be
my opposite but now he's uh doing really
great at alibaba research
and that is a really great example uh in
my opinion over how
set solvers can help uh to solve a very
very
problematic very like uh untrackable and
trackable problem in the industry
so previous talks were like showing how
powerful
hammers we have this one will be more
about showing nails
and anand is i'm really happy that he
found the time
in his busy schedule so that he can at
the end
a step in and tell us more about
real-world data
the data which he works every day and
then
also maybe give an outline of the
problems that are out there
in industry so hopefully that will also
be
uh motivation that we start to talk to
each other
because you know like if i was not even
the sad developer
could come up with such a nice
improvement i'm pretty sure
that all of you guys you will give
enhanced tools that he will be able to
improve
a couple of thousand times so without
advertisement let me actually go to the
to
to a talk and uh
we all use clouds today right even this
talk i see it's recorded will be on the
cloud
and uh all our data on the cloud and we
somehow
rely on the fact that our data is always
there
that if we need our data we just will
always be able to access that
but then of course question is is this
really the case and now
to motivate uh our research let me start
with the very very very simplified
version of the cloud you have see here
a couple of servers and let's assume you
replicated this data over
three different servers three different
servers well
on the surface they are not really maybe
they have connected through
several switches but still nevertheless
they're a couple of switches
they're not really so much dependent and
we assume our data is available
all the time now if you look at uh
a little bit closer you will see that if
this router dies
then also the other two switches that
are connecting to this router will die
and we won't be able to access our data
so then now this is a simple problem and
you can say whether this really happens
in the practice i mean
you know but the fact is it indeed does
so what you see
here uh what they showed you this very
simple example
is just mimicking a problem that this
happened at
amazon web service then i remember that
because that was approximately time when
i came to the states and everyone was
very upset people could not
access their facebook lots of uh there
was lots of complaints but i don't
don't want to just trash amazon i want
to also show you know like the
problems like this we can constantly
read about them and they are just some
sorts of copy pastes uh from
from existing news and now
of course when a problem like this
appears it will capture
the eye of a systems community and uh
there were many
approaches that were working in that
direction where they actually say okay
if uh in summary they have all the time
the same uh
team if failure like this has happened
let's do troubleshoot the system let's
see
what has happened so that we can solve
problem after the outage occurs
and uh of course now you can think about
if that means
longer system downtime well prolonged uh
recovery and uh we are all now in
pandemics so
we know that cure is actually it's much
better that we don't come to the
face that we need to cure something that
we actually will not
be in the face that we want to prevent
disease
instead of trying to cure that and this
was
exactly um the work that
when and when anand was at yale started
to work
on so uh what he did was he developed
his
uh first approach towards that solving
that problem
so uh he uh i will describe that system
which
he called indus and that was the first
uh system that was addressing this
problem and then we started to chat we
were actually
similar same building same same floor so
we started to talk and see
whether there is a similar event there
is a better solution
and i guess to this audience i really
don't
need to sell one should you set solvers
but you will see
how nicely and easily we could model
this problem that you see
using set solvers so that will be as i
said it's really application talk
and then after that anand will tell you
how to take this applied to the real
world
uh cloud and tell you more about the
problems that are out there in community
and hopefully you will then also after
that start to talk to him and
bring even more problems so now let me
now start first with the
this project called indes as you can see
it was a
project published at osdi so this is
again another system conference
and what was what was uh indus doing
actually it worked in couple of steps
the first one is
uh it would collect all the data about
network
and then when banshee would have that
all this data who is connected how is
connected
who relies on what then actually they
would all this data would be used
to model something that is called fault
graph
now some of you uh might say like oh
photograph like in a
min cut set exactly in such type of uh
fault graph and then we need it once we
have a fault graph and we say like
okay what will have to happen that you
know like that the system crashes
then we actually will have to find all
these configurations
that are causing the system to crash
so now let me start to give you an
overview how it was working like
first part is pretty uh would probably
belong to some networking conference
so we'll just kind of give you some
details but uh
you know like uh it's not that much sat
related
so we actually used existing tools so
there is a tool
uh if you look at the if you look at the
example here very simple
network there is a tool called nsd miner
and the tool would that the tool would
actually us can network and derive all
the data
in the following form that you will have
for example here we have i have source
that
server one then i have uh it it's
connected via internet
it can reach core one and all the data
were actually collected
by this tool called nsd miner and it
were never given to
us a and it would be stored in the
database
now once we had this relational
description of the problem
then we immediately could go to the next
step
which was let's build this uh dependency
so let's recall again our initial uh
replication system that we had you know
like you put things to
on the couple of servers and even easier
let's assume you only put things to two
servers
so you know that your configuration
your replicating system will fail you
won't be able
to access your data if every single
of your servers fails right i will have
server one will fail
and notice end also server two will fail
so okay that's kind of reasonable that
you can assume if all of them fails then
i know that i cannot
access my uh my data however now let's
look into the servers
so when server bank will fail well it
will fail if it's hardware fails
or now notice it's not actually we don't
even put and anymore
now it's enough that one of those things
fails it if
it hardware will fail or it net for
successful fail
all its software will fail and so on i
mean and we can continue on then we can
look
into while the network will fail so all
this was
also again constructed automatically
first step was like
analyte net analyze network using nsd
miner
say so uh save it in this relational
database
pull out and construct this graph which
will actually explains
who depends on what and how now if you
look at this
so now we talk about young who was a
debt i'm not still aware that
formal methods are the best things in
the world so uh
they try to use uh something called uh
min cut solver but
as you probably know this is the np
complete problem well the same like set
solvers
but uh nevertheless uh it wasn't really
scaling pretty well
so what then they did they said well you
know like we need to just get
approximate feelings so what they would
do at every
root uh at every leaf they would flip a
coin
and then it would be either it wouldn't
be able to say either it fails or not
so now if we assume that it failed then
uh
then we will put this hex always assume
that it didn't fail
and practically base you will
immediately get one configuration saying
like
if aggregation switch fails and
aggregations which two
of two spells and or they didn't fail
and when we propagate it
then we will know whether the main
configuration fail or not
so now you can see this is the basis for
monte carlo method right
so they would repeat this process many
many times and the more you will repeat
the more accurate description of the of
the
compositions that need to fail
simultaneously
so that original uh deployment fails
you would achieve more and more of them
so
now you can look at that and you will
say well there's clearly several
issues right one of them is that it is
hard really to express
a diverse auditing task right we can
also ask like you can just say like
will it fail and find me this uh other
uh
parts which will fail but you cannot ask
maybe any anything anymore
what is the minimum component which is
what min cut said would
answer and uh those things you will not
able to
answer so i mean sorry i didn't say
others the other one is like
it did it was really slow you will see
based on the result that
uh that we will show at the end and one
of thing is like
you can just kind of pinpoint the
problem there was nothing to do that you
solved the problem
so what we did uh we started talking
then we said like well we should do set
solvers for that
and we proposed engine which is called
which we called
rap auditing engine and let me tell you
what was the secret sauce like we could
develop a new domain specific auditing
language
uh that could easily express diverse
auditing tasks and that was pretty easy
because
once we modeled everything as a set
formula then it was just like
uh boiled down to find the minimal
unsatisfiable core
uh add the additional constraints and it
was constantly
well done to solving constraints and
it was much faster well thanks you thank
for thanks for everyone for developing
a new and fast set solvers and in
addition we
described uh well outlined how the
synthesis would work for
this approach how we would give
a more uh how we would not only be able
to say
look this will fail but we would even
give the user feedback
but if you change something if you put
it maybe on different server
then you will reduce your failure
probability
so that's uh what we've done now let's
uh
we go back to the problem that we
started with uh again simplified version
but what does it mean if we want to
identify that this
i mean observing just the picture we can
see that this router is problematic if
it dies our whole
replication system will die but how it
works we more or less
have this auditing problem that we will
say well
write down uh i'm using server one and
server two
and can you rank me this is what we
called risk graph component
and we would get uh the user would need
to do this what is in the blue box well
what is in the blue box is a black box
for user what would user would get
excuse me user would just get the answer
which will say
well you're uh looking at the these
components your most
problematic is this core one if it dies
you don't have
uh you don't have access to your
replication system application data
but also you will is the same if uh
aggregation switch one and to die at the
same time
you are in the same trouble so if you
look what was behind that
we were using again all things that they
described that's why i spent so much
time
talking about this fault graph then we
would com
then we would convert this into cnf
uh form and use weighted exit solvers
now i don't this is don't want to go so
much into auditing language and all the
auditing details maybe just to tell you
uh interesting concepts remember i was
complaining
that we didn't have enough
expressibility with this
old approach so now what we can do we
can say
let me rank the components let me rank
the devices which are most
likely to fail what is exactly if i
develop a certain uh
uh if i want to k if i care only about
one
replication system what is the failure
probability can you give me some
recommendations so
all this is now in our language and not
to give you the semantics of this one
uh let me excuse me
um so you user can write
exp properties like that and how we
envision it will work
here is our database that already
analyzed uh
network here is our user rights auditing
problem as the one as you have seen here
and and then uh we it user will
based on this um based on this network
use
uh there in our auditing engine which is
actually
again based on set solvers user will get
a report
telling us telling us smallest what is
the failure probability or what we ever
be ask in our auditing problem
now let me actually look more i guess we
i promise to
albert application talk so let me
actually look into application right
so first i already mentioned several
times three
groups in default graphs and i guess
name is pretty much
self dis descript the descriptive
this is a group in the fall graph such
that if this group
of the nodes fails then we know that the
root
failure of root not to happen so here we
look here that a2
is clearly one such a risk group but
also at the same time
a1 and a3 jointly are also this group
because if a1 and a3 dies
then we know that both of a even and the
second in one which is actually e2
should die too and then we know that we
don't have our deployment
but if only a1 dies that's fine because
if a1 dies
then even like left event won't be
accessible
but the right line is still there and we
have access to our data
so now looking at that you can clearly
see that this will stake it's taking
account that we have
end and org nodes clearly we can encode
all this as a four mil boolean formula
and practically the problem boils down
to find satisfaction assignments to
boolean formula
so every satisfac assignment will
represent a risk group
now you can also ask do you have
negations yes we will do have negations
but we are getting there so initially it
looks like we don't have them
but you can see so now you can also look
at the risk groups and you say well if
a2 and a3 dies that's you know like bad
but it's much worse if a2 dies because
it's only one of them right
so then the question is like whether all
risk groups are created equal and
clearly not because
if they're smaller you know like there
is much
less chance much higher chance that only
one thing will die
that five things will die simultaneously
although we know how it's in life
probably five things will die
simultaneously but
anyway we needed not only to find what
a typical problem would say find me a
solution
but find me maybe the best solution in
that case so we wanted to find
top k minimal risk groups and
we looked into something which is called
mean cost set problem
i don't actually look into chat are they
any questions or is everything clear so
far
everyone is with me everything is clear
okay perfect thank you very much then if
you have any questions just
uh please stop so let me then go uh
uh let me go back to mean costs that
problem right
so you all know what is said problem
right said problem just means
i have a set of variables and i want to
find a solution
but there is uh if you each variable
would also have
a cost so then you actually want to find
a cost
solution that cost them the least money
so in uh
and if you'll ask now how is this
related to our size
well we can simply say let's cost of
each variable be one
in that case mean cost solution to the
problem is indeed finding the solution
of the minimal size but then
interestingly enough
once we started to model into that
direction then we realized
but it's not also again not only that
all it could
all uh these components are equal also
it's not the case
that all the devices are equal some
devices are
of really good quality but some devices
will constantly you know like
guys some of they have different failure
probabilities
and now having again the same approach
of mean coset problem
uh we could assign uh
the we could actually find this
component which was not necessarily
the smallest in the size but looking
into failure probabilities of each
device
again we could find the minimal failure
probability
so now let's look maybe what would be
here in the our typical or
when we just focused on the size we you
can see i'm saying each
of the each of the components has
value one that means you know like it
will of it
you know like i want to just it you know
like i want to just see the size
and in that case i can easily find that
my minimal
uh component is actually exactly a2
now if uh i look uh if i want to maybe
put different
components let's say if i will say i
have a
uh maybe failure probability of a one is
ten percent failure probability of a two
is
thirty percent and failure probability
of a two is twenty percent so
clearly those are pumped up numbers but
just for easier
illustration then you can simply say you
will again additionally need to
divide multiply right if a1 and a2 die
at the same a three die at the same time
we will see that then failure
probability
is zero zero zero two and uh then again
using the same reasoning as before we
find it
since this one it has the clearly the
highest probability
we report that one uh
now uh you can now kind of
notice that i already mentioned if a1
dies and a3 dies at the same time i
multiply those things right and if you
look at the problem
it is not exactly what problem talks
about it's multiplication it's
addition so let me show you a
trick that we did so how to how to
reduce
addition to multiplication of course
using algorithms
and i should probably ask anan if he
still remembers the
the things because what this happened
was like okay you know like if we use
algorithms
if algorithms if i'm really tired i'm
sorry
if we use logarithms uh that means
you know like we want we can really
reduce multiplication
to uh had a multiplication
to uh addition but then again the
problem was why we needed
negative value was because if you look
at logarithmic function it goes like
this and we actually
needed the the other way so that's why
we use negative value
and we needed to multiply by a hundred
for simple reason because the numbers
we were getting were too small to
actually
compare so this was just let's multiply
everything with 100 so that we can at
least compare
compare the values so and uh again
using you know like this simple tricks
we were again
in the same uh problem that we have
min cost uh a problem and we again try
to solve that
and uh how to find uh now now here comes
where to come our negations uh so far
you have only seen
and and or but how do we find top k
critical risk groups
maybe our solution was relatively naive
because what we did we would find
top for top solution then we would
negate that solution and repeat the
process so
you know maybe there is maybe there is
something that looks like oh there is so
much easier and more elegant
uh solution we will we would like to
hear that from you
but with us it was working pretty smooth
because you know i usually don't want to
see
top 30 things like it was just give me
top five or top three
to see what is the most at the risk at
that time
and uh that's it i guess uh now uh if i
one thing that is also that we were kind
of very inspired uh by
uh cool dip stop was uh computing the
failure probability of the
all system because if you think about
that now imagine we have our system and
we create the graph and i'm asking you
so what is overall failure probability
if we already have
uh we already have those numbers
and that is how you ask that well the
failure probability will be more or less
finding uh models you know like as we
said like
each positive solution is each
satisfying assignment is uh is uh
corresponds to one failure group
one failure uh event
which means that if we find how many
models we have
we actually have found the overall
failure probability of the system so we
didn't need to
run our k loop but it was enough that we
actually just do model counting
and then we uh divide better 2 to the n
excuse me there is a question or
i don't see they see something
you did use this or is this something
you want to do
this is what we already did implement
so um there is a question sure what is
the
scale of this problem how many variables
are we are getting there we are getting
there i mean
you have to stay with us until the end
yeah
yeah yeah so i will show this in like
two three slides
and then and then we'll actually show
you that how to work in even on
even bigger uh things so anyway so there
we are what else
um right so we could use this uh failure
probability with model counting
only if we assume that all uh
all the all the boxes are equal because
in that case
if all the boxes are equal then their
failure probability is
0.5 you know like either it will fail or
it won't and then we could actually use
modern counters right
however if you remember when i showed
you picture before
here everyone each of them had a
different probability
and then how again we did it was a
little bit you know like again maybe
there is a smarter way
but for us it was a tick that worked
pretty neatly what we did was you know
like if it
if it's already one over half then it's
fine
otherwise we would just kind of you know
here was
the trick was one over eight one over
eight is
we have to kind of introduce three fake
uh
fake uh nodes which would actually again
each of them have a probability one over
two and then when you multiply
failure probability of this whole node
on the top it is exactly one over eight
now in reality you know like you won't
really get one over eight you will get
something one over seven but then we
would just do approximation because
also this failure probability of certain
device it's not like
this is really precise this is like
estimated failure probability
so that's the trick that we use and
now thank you for the question now we
want to come how fast it is
and uh it is much faster
oh no i want do i have time for repair
maybe let me quickly go to tell you how
fast it was
and then you can actually see so um
like i already said we had a first
implementation which was
a failure sampling that was the work
that enanded as a part of his phd
studies
and so we really had an expert who knew
how to write all these editing tasks
and this was the line of codes he needed
to describe
all these editing tasks that was
encoding problem using some mini
minimal cuts at solver and this was just
using our uh
our array l language and you can see the
reason why we actually
could do this well because we already
knew which problems arise in the
practice
so all our uh components that we
introduced were actually
kind of tuned towards that that we can
easily express
what uh what system administrator wants
to
ask about a system and at that time
we were younger naive and we only had
our system here
called the sis stu at that time we could
even still use in person
uh student uh student lab
verse we actually and we could simulate
various topologies
so we had uh we came with the topologies
that would have 140
routers this is the number of switches
and so on
so all these topologies were simulating
uh using a tool again from networking
that is
used you kind of give provide a
parameters
and then actually then you actually get
a topology which corresponds to
real-life real-life topologies so if you
can see at that time
we actually even had topologies c which
was
um not d which was a bit bigger but the
you know like then we really needed to
wait for results to get
out but i know that nan will tell you
how he actually used this in the real
real world setting so to go here
topology c has around 70
000 devices and if you look how fast it
was
let me actually show you so when we were
using min cast
algo mean cut set algorithm right it
because we used um
existing tools i forgot name but uh it
was super accurate but it also took a
little bit of time
we really needed to like time to compute
that
the the on this topology questions that
we were asking
however when you would use uh index that
was this monte carlo simulator
it was getting there you can see after
10 rounds you would actually get
accuracy of around 20 after million
rounds
you would get accuracy you know ten to
the five million rounds you would get
accuracy of uh thirty percent and after
ten to seven rounds
you're almost here in the time but
you're still with the accuracy
of their answer which is closely to 40
percent
so if you would kind of imagine here uh
line you could really see exponential
growth now
again thank you all guys develo asset
solvers
developers we really appreciate that
because when we run all these tasks
on the 70 000 notes we actually got
around 300 times uh speed up so we were
like
really happy with that and
i guess anand wants to take over here
but we
if we will have a time we will just kind
of tell you more about repair but anan
since people wanted to see how things
are working well
uh maybe oh no let me do you want to
share or should or do you want to talk
yeah i can share my screen yeah so uh
thank you thank you uh let me
share um my screen
yeah so um yeah so thank you very much
for uh
story yeah so let's continue that so
after i left the eel i joined the
alibaba group
so i i tried to deploy the direct audit
in
alibaba group uh you know the alibaba is
one of the largest
cloud providers in in this world um so
um we're planning to add a very
beginning we are just
planning to uh use red audio to audit
you know any
update state uh you know service runtime
like showing in you know this picture
but this is because the majority of the
big outages in
our network were caused by the service
updates
such as you know changing the network
depos and upgrading the
software component and dependencies so
our system is named the cloud canary
well it worked well like what russia
just showed but
yeah unfortunately our operators asked
first
whether it could be more faster because
the number of
our update tasks increased
super fast and in most of these times
you know busy time our operators
actually need to
commit one update task every five hours
so in addition actually you know because
we are
trying to target the industry uh scale
services
so actually we have i'm sorry and on
quick question when you say update task
you mean upgrading software components
on the under the cloud
uh yes exactly yeah so including both
network and
and software for example you can um say
uh remove
one link between the two switches and
add another link
between uh you know another two switches
this is one update
and then another update might be uh we
upgraded the version of a software
um from you know 1.0 to
2.0 so just to reiterate you were saying
you were you had one update task
for five hours is that what you were
saying that was the rate at which you're
doing updates
right right so yeah okay
thank you so uh yeah but
this is this is actually a great
question uh what i want to emphasize is
update is very very important for for
our operators because
we did a lot of updates you know every
day so and uh
you know update is dangerous we we need
to uh
you know prevent the problems resulting
from the you know the update
and so so we're targeting the you know
industry level uh services so so
uh it contains hundreds of thousands of
components
so uh i remember just a question about
the scale
uh of the dataset so because i'm not
allowed to
expose the absolute number of our
components but what i can say is
actually we
we're targeting the the components the
number of components
is higher than 100 000
it's more than that but i cannot expose
the absolute number for that i mean our
uh
you know real network right so oh yeah
and
we have a a new requirement whether
whether we can do fast
so um how to address this problem and
yeah because we are targeting much more
uh components in in the real scale right
and we have a key inside um because we
are targeting the service updates so
typically the service update
you know just a change they do not
typically change
too many uh components from the previous
updated snapshot
so so uh we can just audit the
differential parts between the
previous and the updated snapshots
instead of you know auditing the entire
updated snapshot from scratch
so this is our key insight and so uh
with this key insight we developed the
algorithm for cloud canary
and which allows us to to only audit the
incremental parts
with an um within an updated snapshot
and so you know we're we're now using
wrap audit for the initialization phase
like shown in this
picture and and during the service run
time we just
run you know cloud canary to um do the
incremental auditing
and because uh so this algorithm
actually is not
uh it's not trivial uh so uh due to the
limit of time
i i cannot go through the detail but i i
will show you the uh
the key the key inside about this
algorithm and you can read our paper for
more details this work was published in
the sdi uh which is our top top network
conference
um last year so the key inside here is
uh
the triangles here mean the snapshot for
the uh photograph
and you know the first thing is we we
analyze we
we get the default graph yeah and we
we found the the border nodes the border
nodes means the
black nodes in in this in this uh
photograph
and the border nodes are actually the
root nodes for the up
updated sub photographs and so after we
find the
uh the the border the border node and we
only need to use the
sensor to to identify the the risk of
the risk groups
in the sub photographs and after that we
also propose another algorithm to merge
the result
from top to bottom from uh the bottom to
out to to up
to get the final results and this is
very uh interesting algorithm so
if you are interested in that just to
read our paper and actually during this
process we only you know um
audit the uh the delta um between the
updates so let me show some results
uh we so this is a real result we we did
this real uh deployment in our
network and from this picture so the s
one two three four are the real update
so
from this picture we can observe that uh
the you know the um
the interval between two updates are
actually very
very fast it's just a short time and so
we did a lot of you know updates
uh in this service runtime and if we use
the existing
work to try to do this audit then they
cannot
finish the task um on time and because
another update will come soon right and
so if
we use the cloud canary because we only
uh audit the
the data between the snapshot so
actually we can
finish the uh auditing task on time so
this is the key thing um
happened in our real network and um
so so in this uh cloud canary that
result that you're showing here uh i
have two questions here
one is is the incrementality key to the
fact that it's much faster than reported
or okay
again i was wondering why cloud canary
is so much better than
oh because because we only audit the
data between between the
the two snapshots right so the existing
work
actually including the direct audit they
audited
the entire photograph from scratch yeah
and
because between the two updates we
actually only have the small part
uh is updated so we you know what we
need to do is just to to analyze the the
delta part
yeah and get the final result this is
the key inside
is that clear yes
yeah make sense thanks
uh okay so this is the real result here
um
we analyzed our real uh cloud
so um we we have we have the following
uh
results from from you know our uh the
case study
so uh the micro service updates
sometimes uh introduce the
the common dependency for example the
authentication
component and access control system so
we observe some say
access control is the rule uh which
might be the
common dependency so if that rule uh is
wrong
or uh it's incorrect and it it's very
likely
to cause the car laser failure across
the entire network actually wait wait
you know
sometimes that really happened but i
cannot expose that the real outages here
uh so in power source is another one so
um the power source typically support a
lot of components
say uh you know the two uh power sources
support the
uh thousands of routers or or thousands
of servers
and if the power source um you know some
some problems happen in power source so
that
it's also dangerous and we we also need
to use our system to audit whether some
you know common dependency
power source is introduced in the
network area it's uh
also common the for example the average
venture h and tor switch
that happened uh you know sometimes lead
to the
correlated failures across the entire uh
network and so actually we we detected a
lot of
you know such dangerous um common
dependencies and you know we
we we fund them long time and so can can
solve a lot of problems from
our network so so the wrap audit
is is the first system that you know use
the disaster to finish the efficient
um audit for the very correlated failure
and cloud canary actually is the first
system we we use them
in the in the real world and uh to audit
the
you know the real-time uh update and so
actually we also evaluate the cloud
canary in the
real uh railroad data and like what i
just showed so so this this part is just
a talk about
uh one concrete example about how
can we apply disaster in the uh
you know both academia in the industry
to build a real system um so so in the
in the end of my talk
i would i would tell you uh in
the network analysis domain um
what what type of systems we can build
to uh based on the sat
or s70 solver and i also want to thank
the nikolai and so we we actually after
i
joined the alibaba i widely used smg
solver
to to build a lot of uh verification
system
in our network so so here i want to show
this um
i'm sorry yeah you know there's another
question by current yeah
so the updates are incremental is the
sad solving also incremental this that's
all that's used in cloud canary is that
leveraging we i actually do not
you use the incremental thing for for
the uh for the sas hour we just
use that the algorithm to to analyze to
extract
the the incremental part and directly
use the original sets or you know to
analyze the incremental part
thank you thanks
so because because i'm not quite the
disaster guy so
um i really want to you know do
something smart thing
in in the session but unfortunately i
didn't do that so what what i can do is
to design an orgasm to to
to extract the you know incremental part
and use the original sensor to analyze
it
so this is what what i did okay anyway
yeah so maybe also to tell you uh we
uh when we were using set solver i think
we were using
the we went to competition found the
most the fastest set solver that was
publicly available right advantages
right so that's you know it's not based
on a smart
insights and techniques so that's why i
thought it would it's really great that
anan is giving a talk so that you can
kind of provide so much more feedback
and uh
yeah you know bring more tools that we
could use yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah what we did is just to oh you
know um
take take a look at the uh the ranking
list about the sas
our uh competition and then just you
know select what one
we can use and to apply that in your
system this is what we did
yeah let's thought what is that uh we
use a
super mario or uh
and also we also use the motor counter
from uh
the crew uh yeah and yeah that that
that that's the motor counterpart for
for the uh failure failure probability
competition uh presented by rudiger
yeah okay thank you thanks
um okay so yeah yeah so so this picture
you just want to show
um a you know big picture about the
state of the art
that apply the sas our ice empties are
in
formal network analysis i actually
classified them into three
groups the uh rigorous network analysis
um
and verification and network synthesis i
guess
you guys are super familiar with these
uh you know three domains
and this is actually what i'm exactly
working on in the alibaba
and so the first type is uh um
is the either the rigorous track
checking you know for the net for the
network
and the in this scenario that typically
uh the operator expressed
their their uh specification uh say in
first all the logic
and then convey the specification to the
system
and the system automatically analyze the
target network
and the key challenge here is how to
model the network
or how to extract a reasonable network
abstraction from
the underneath and so uh some existing
work have
has been uh proposed for example like
what uh justin roosevelt talked about
the derived audio and indus belong to
this domain
um and we also have uh you know we also
observe
another uh word from microsoft they they
use the um
the solver to check and and test the uh
the configuration for the software
so the second domain is the former
network checking
so actually the network configuration um
is
is a big problem and the operators
typically uh made a lot of
wrong things in in in the configuration
but the configuration
is the key thing for the network they
generated the routing table they uh
control the forwarding behaviors of the
network and so using the
the smt server in the network
verification is very important direction
in the network and system area and so in
this domain
actually the uh operator expressed the
specification
about the uh the correctness of the
network for example
um the reachability i one router can
talk with the router i want router one
can toggle with router two
in the uh in in this class and and uh so
i just want to check whether
the routing table is default is correct
and and here the challenge is how can we
correctly
uh express our intent and and and
the the network model whether the
network model is is uh represented
correctly
and another important thing is is um
we want to use the smt solver to check
whether the network model meets our uh
specification right and so typically in
in in practice we we
we found now the the verification
algorithm just like
and whether we can speed up the dsm icm
disorder to you know
um to speed up this this process and so
a lot of status are
proposed uh in the past years for
example uh
in data plan verification we we know the
uh wire flow and
nod led is also the negative work and
very much like this work
yeah and the control plane verification
include the uh muscle waiver
and the erp i strongly suggest you you
guys
read the papers and i you know in our
system and network
community we really want want to have
the super fast
smg solver to speed up the existing uh
system
so so in the network synthesis of uh
area
the operator typically uh expressed the
specification
and in this case we do not have any
configuration for our network
and writing the configuration is very
very hard so what we want to just
uh propose some synthesis algorithm and
this augment can uh generate the the
network configuration
based on the stack and in this area
now of course the challenge is uh
is how can we express the intent and
what should be
the synthesis algorithm uh and the state
of the art include
the uh configuration repair and say um
the the firemason fire mission was
another collaboration between uh russia
and me and her student um to to
automatically repair the firewall
and also the configuration synthesis and
uh including the
uh c9 that complete you know like um
like showing in this picture and what i
want to emphasize
is so all the uh stats all the only work
i just
talked about focused on the in the
academia uh
area but whether we could build build
some
something in the in the um in the
industry
uh to to verify the global scale the
deployment
actually the cloud canary is is one uh
instance for the uh called the global
scale uh deployment
and and for the network verification and
the network
synthesis we have gap and we need a lot
of work in this
in this part uh so after i joined
alibaba actually
we we built we built a system uh named
named hoyen
which can use item desire to uh verify
the configuration
and of course in microsoft research and
nikola had
had a team to build another data plan
verification system
um published in sitcom two years ago i
think yeah i remember
okay so uh i think both of the the
systems
prove that um the smd server could be
absolutely
applied in the industry and to do the
real you know the
real world uh verification for for the
network this is important thing
and and in the um the network
synthesis area um so i
i also built another uh system alibaba
to to synthesize
the aclu for for our uh network and
because this asl
rule is is different from um the
firewall because
this acl is the in-network aco because
we have a lot of switches and on
interest rates we have different
acos and and this is um so all the
excels are different and those
work together to coordinate control the
uh
the reachability and this is very uh
challenging to
generate the the acl for this
distributed sighting
so again um the the picture shows a lot
of state-of-the-art
but you know all of them apply the smt
solver
to enable the verification and so thank
you very much for the community
and what we need uh in the future is the
faster uh
smd sorry and sensor and animal you know
functions say like
like the you know incremental uh speed
up or something yeah
and and and we we were very happy to use
some you know
uh interesting uh smd solo sessor to
speed up our uh
tracking and verification so again this
is the end of my talk um
yeah and uh so so in this talk
we we talked about some some
applications for the
uh existing sensor and smg star uh
in know in the real world and um i'm
happy to take any
questions thank you
um can i say something yeah
this is really cool i like i like the
application thank you
i think we need to see more applications
of this technology
so that you know the secret about you
know what we can do
uh is is not the secret anymore that
other
application other communities can
actually uh
become familiar with it and they can
start using it i think
um as a tech community we have not done
as much in kind of reaching out to other
communities to show them that what
what we can do so
that has been around now for 20 some
years
go ahead thank you thank you
very nice very nice hello uh
i cannot hear you
i'm getting uh getting a echo
somehow not sure what's i'll but
maybe you want to go to the vehicle yeah
okay so
so the echo seems to be gone and i guess
you can hear me
so for for the uh
for the risk group um enumeration
so you enumerate top risk groups and
then check
whether you have certain guarantees
under top
risk groups okay so the question is
with is there a formulation uh
using quantifiers are you solving a
problem there
exists some configuration such that
under all uh
certain some property so so
if you had this quantified formulation
you could
ask to the sad community what are the
clever ways of
solving this quantifier and so so one
method that so i think colleagues in the
networking space are using is is
employing
linear programming dualities when
there's a subset that
exhibits strong duality so maybe in the
set space
there there are some other i mean
there's a
variant of this and i wonder if you can
like
you use your work to to inspire this sad
community around this
question
listen by anon and i look at each
other's oh
there is some sort of quantification
that i didn't present and that was in
the form of synthesis
we if in the quantification doesn't
exist in the language
as we have and also our synthesis uh
is a pretty it's relatively simple and
primitive because what we did was uh
you would mod practically say whether
there exists uh
deployment such that you know like let's
say failure probability of deployment
falls under i know twenty zero point
twenty percent
and that we can show that there is this
quantification that is
whether there exists one deployment but
what we do
is uh uh we are solving this
more or less on demand in the sense that
we are constructing the tree
and see soon that we see the tree is uh
violating the constraints
we prune those branches so it's
not you know like it is if you look at
the description of the algorithm it's
pretty much you know like
build the tree just violate cut it away
build continue
this prune away that's it that's
obviously
very reasonable and then the question is
whether
does it scale under say
how how does it scale with the sizes of
networks and then
so so the a number of faults group
combinations right so if you look for
paragraphs
and i don't really recall baby do you
remember
um i i cannot remember that um
it's uh so it's in in uh
in the real in the real real world data
we we didn't we didn't use that but uh
but in um for uh for for the ripe audit
i think this scale is i think
uh what let me see
ten thousand i guess they decompose we
have ten thousand components
and we can synthesize within us
just several several minutes but again i
guess nikolas question
might be uh talked about in uh when
we want to identify risk groups whether
we consider
whether we take into account the the
quantifier or something right
nikolai is that your your question
actually is so the
of course they're very dif they're in in
your last slide you had the
different categories of synthesizing and
network configuration
and and depending on which line you're
in
you have a different uh kind of problem
you're checking and then
maybe it's it's in the last in the last
line where you're
where the query is you know find a fixed
configuration such that yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah got it and to solve
that you can't
just prune one brand at a time you want
to find the fixed configuration such
that for all branches
depending we did we did take into
account that
uh you know the the conveyors like what
you mentioned in the hoya system
but but yeah what uh what what i think
the rubik's just talked about is the
cloud canary you know they're a
different
system but in our configuration
verification we did consider that
and because sometimes we we want to
check whether you know
uh uh a specific a specific
configuration rule has some problem or
whether you know the reachability goes
through from a specific
path you know including this to specify
the component or earth switches you know
in that case we we did consider that
thing in in the hawaiian system
which is the configuration verification
system right
now but but the whole question is how to
inspire the sad community and i believe
that there's one
um angle that that says whether it's uh
say metric some some qbf with their
probabilities or
or weights or otherwise and
compile it into um
say say small formulas or solve these
formulas
i was going to echo the same point
nikoloi if
if he can get a benchmark suite
of instances uh from rusicha and
in on that would be fantastic i think
that would uh uh encourage the set
community to be more engaged
it is a set of hundred challenge
problems for example
but i think there's also theoretical i
think yeah
exactly yeah
can we hope to get benchmarks for zita
and in on
but there wait none is there we
disappear
so uh benchmarks from upsla that's the
one that we
i was presenting are definitely
available i don't know for alibaba
benchmarks are they
a lot i mean are they
it's kind of shame i will talk to anand
if
alibaba benchmarks are available or even
if they can be analyzed
and on my somehow i will definitely
encourage him to submit
and to contact you i mean not now you
know each other so that's
that was uh that's totally important
right yeah
absolutely okay thank you for thank you
for a fantastic talk uh and on end
rosita uh because he wouldn't even tell
you how many notes
so i think they're going to be very
protective of that benchmark um
your crash so i'm putting a nun on the
speaker sorry but that's why i'm
answering because anand is calling me to
tell me that he crashed
the internet in my in my home was
was crashed because uh some guys outside
are building
uh yeah the subway or something
after the question is that of me sorry
yeah no and then the question was just
um do will you make are your benchmarks
the ones that were into your follow-up
systems will they be
publicly available or are they already
publicly available
our companies do not allow that
so the answer is that he cannot because
company doesn't a system is available if
understood properly but not to the
benchmarks
but our all right so the right the right
audience
is available right all these and past
the rfi
evaluation right because it is totally
open source
you can ask them to use that but uh but
call the canary and the uh you know the
system i built in alibaba is not
available
okay okay thank you
all right thanks again thank you thank
you sorry
for money yeah i'm really sorry don't
worry don't worry
yeah yeah okay thank you
feeling something outside they are
building the subways
don't worry it happens now we showed
that networks really can be un
reliable thank you
bye
so thank you everybody uh thank you for
the great speakers
so we are ending this session today and
i believe
albert uh there is going to be a gather
town or i think there was some kind of a
seminar too i think by the
by the uh i'm not sure about this to
tell the truth
by the mentors yeah maybe
can i also say as an organizer or the
other workshop so on monday we are
starting
with our seminar our workshop which will
be
on software synthesis and we will have
exciting new uh exciting very tutorial
that
given by ben finkbeiner so all of you
who would like to know a little bit more
i mean you're sad people you're using
booleans
you want to learn more about how to use
them in the synthesis
please come on monday for the synthesis
workshop
okay uh there is a comment uh by sybil
uh
the comment is i would be particularly
interested in benchmarks for model
counting
okay let me send this to anna
all right uh albert is there anything
else
announcement well yeah there's now the
other town is in
uh link is in the chat yeah so yeah i
just want to thank everybody for the
great uh
talks so today it was nice to see we
started with model counting
and then we followed with smt and then
the very last talk was
putting both things together right yeah
so thank you very much for the great
talks and
see you next time thank you everybody
bye bye
bye